the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie
[Music]
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
eight endgame video today I want to
answer one of the questions you left me
but first I promised out what announced
the new details of the giveaway this
time I will be giving away a copy of the
world of Ice and Fire book it's
basically like an encyclopedia of the
unknown history of Westeros and the game
of Thrones so if you would like to win a
copy of the book there is a link down
below good luck
now let's get started as I said at the
beginning of the video I wanted to
answer some of your questions in this
one question in particular gave me the
idea for the video about a month or two
ago I made a video about the best ways
to end Game of Thrones and then I made a
video about the worst ways to end Game
of Thrones
after reading this question I figured it
was time to make a video about some of
the saddest ways to end Game of Thrones
but keep in mind this is just my opinion
I'm sorry if I mispronounced your name
but this question comes from Suraj he
actually did ask me three different
things but I only want to focus on
question number three because I
completely disagree with the other two
number three says John will die without
knowing his true identity before you
even left me the question this is
something I have wondered myself as we
all know Game of Thrones is almost over
and I know we all been thinking about
how the show ends I think most of us
can't agree there will be some sort of a
bittersweet ending this is something the
producers have said and this is how
George RR Martin's said he wanted to end
his books this is a bit of a step in the
duck
right can you give us an insight to how
the books might end is there gonna be a
happy end in a sad end then I've think
there's gonna be a bittersweet ending
and I've always taken my influence from
junior Tolkien and if you've read Lord
of the Rings Sauron is defeated in the
ring is destroyed in the end but it's
not a happy happy ending there's there's
a real sense of things lost too and and
I found that very powerful
very moving and so I think my ending
will also have a bittersweet tone I hope
if I can bring it off the way I want to
bring it off ever since I heard those
words come out of George's mouth I've
been wondering what are some of the
different things that could happen that
would make the ending of Game of Thrones
bittersweet now keep in mind what is
bittersweet for me might not be
bittersweet for you but since the
question was left for me I also want to
talk about how I would feel if this did
happen well Jon Snow died without
knowing his true identity my answer for
this would be no because I think Jon
will find out who his parents are but
just because I think he will find out
doesn't mean that it will actually
happen the truth about Jon Snow's
parentage has been one of the best-kept
secrets in all of Westeros this is a
secret that Ned Stark took to his grave
but there was a time back in season 1
when Ned Stark promised to tell John
about his mother is my mother alive does
she know about me where I am where I'm
going
she care the next time we see each other
we'll talk about your mother
improve nice unfortunately Ned died
before he could ever speak to John again
and as of right now there are only a few
characters that know the truth
Helen Reed knows because he was there
the day lianna was found in a bed of
blood
Helen Reed found Ned's still holding Lee
on his body and he actually had to
unlock their hands besides Howland Reed
we know brain stark and Sam Tarly know
the truth because they both talked about
it in the very last episode so you have
to ask yourself could something happen
that would prevent them from telling
John the truth or could something happen
to John before they're able to tell him
I would say just about anything is
possible
thankfully us as an audience were given
confirmation in the show Game of Thrones
answered one of the biggest questions
throughout the fandom and I'm so happy
they did because I needed to know the
truth I would say this was sweet because
they gave us the answer before the show
ended John has wondered who his mother
was his whole life and I have to be
honest if John doesn't get this answer
before he dies this would have a very
big impact on me as a viewer and never
met my mother my father wouldn't even
tell me a name I don't know if she's
living or dead this might sound crazy
but I need John to have the closure
before the show ends I have already
prepared myself for the fact that any
character could die next season I mean
this is a show that's already full of
death and the remaining characters still
have two very big problems on their
hands one problem is the night king and
the other problem is Cersei Lannister in
your own Greyjoy you would be foolish to
think your favorite character is
untouchable when we know there will be a
lot of bloodshed in the final season
anyone can die next season and I have
already accepted the fact that some of
the characters I love will die but what
I cannot accept is Jon not finding out
who his parents are I can't even give
you a great answer for why I feel that
way but I want John to get that closure
I already know there is a very good
chance Jon could die in battle but I'm
hoping and praying brain and Sam can
tell John the truth before something bad
happens to either one of them I always
think back to one of Ramsay Bolton's
most powerful quotes
if I win he'll let me go
if you think this has a happy ending you
haven't eaten paying attention if you
think this has a happy ending you
haven't been paying attention you can't
forget what Tyrion Lannister said either
and what about what I want justice
for my sister and her chica
if you want justice you've come to the
wrong place that disagree if you want
justice you've come to the wrong place
keep that in mind because we might not
get what we want and that goes for Jon
Snow too in my opinion this would be a
very sad way to end his story even if he
defeats his enemies since I'm talking
about sad endings let me throw out a few
more scenarios that would just break my
heart like I was saying earlier I am
prepared to see some beloved characters
die if Jon and Daenerys died in the end
I would be able to get over it but if
something happens to their baby that
would be hard for me to get over now I
know Danny's pregnancy has not been
confirmed yet but I am very confident
she's pregnant and I'll be honest I kind
of hope she is pregnant because I want
Jon and Daenerys to be able to further
their bloodlines this is something
Daenerys has won it as well in four
years she thought her dragons would be
your only children but vissarion's death
may pay for life and your family hasn't
seen it's in you're still here I can't
have children who told you that there
weren't you related my husband hasn't
occurred to you she might not have been
a reliable source of information we also
saw the look on John's face when Jorah
Mormont gave Jon a moment to pause and
think that one day he might have
children it's yours it serve you well
your children after you
john has been fighting for so long he
hasn't even considered that he might
have kids because he probably didn't
think he would live long enough to
father children or be allowed to have
kids because he was in the Nights Watch
however John and Daenerys may have an
opportunity to have a child of their own
this was already foreshadowed about half
a dozen times last season so whether you
like the idea or not the show is already
setting this up to happen
I hope John survives the entire show and
I hope Daenerys survives the entire show
but if they die I can't say I would be
surprised now if we find out Danny is
pregnant and something bad happens to
the baby I might pick up my TV and throw
it out the damn window for me that would
be one of the saddest ways to end the
show the final book in George RR
Martin's series is called a dream of
spring and that sounds like an ending
that does have some hope so I would like
to thank Danny's baby what survived
assuming she's pregnant but you just
never know this would not be the first
time Game of Thrones has done something
extremely dark another way Game of
Thrones could end in a very sad way has
to do with one of the most anticipated
reunions a next season I recently made a
video where I listed two top 10 reunions
I'm looking forward to the most and
number one on my list is the Jon and REO
reunion I've always been quite fond of
the members of House Stark and as we all
know this family has been ripped apart
and scattered across multiple continents
for many seasons but the pieces are
slowly starting to be put back together
again
most of the Starks lost contact with
each other ever since the first season
and I know most of us have been dying to
see them all reunite after all this time
John and Sansa finally reunited at
Castle black back in season six and
they've pretty much been together ever
since Jon has had to go on a few
missions here and there but you know
what I mean Shaun's a brain and Arya
have finally reunited as well and
they're all one big happy family for now
but Game of Thrones has done a really
good job at teasing the two stark
reunions everyone is really waiting for
and that is Jon and bran and Jon and
Arya that's because we know how close
they really are
even though Sansa Arya and bran all have
the same mother and father
Jon has had a closer relationship with
Arya and bran so for me personally I
want to see that reunion the most if you
haven't read the book so then you might
not know how
clothes they actually are because game
of thorns hasn't done the best job at
showing this but to be fair it is easier
to get this across in the books because
we get to go inside the characters heads
and see what they're thinking John and
Arya think about each other and pretty
much every book except for a feast for
crows because John is not in that book
but other than that they're always on
each other's mind
we did see Sons to express this a little
bit when she reunited with Arya you
ladies doc John left you in charge he
did I hope he comes back soon I remember
how happy he was to see me when he sees
you his heart will probably stop now if
gameofthrones really wanted to rip my
heart out and throw it on the floor they
would kill John or Arya before they
could ever reunite now I know it doesn't
seem likely because Arya is already at
Winterfell and join us on his way there
but you just never know we even got a
small teaser of John returning to
Winterfell when they showed him in songs
of hugging but we've already seen that I
want to see John and Arya hug but Game
of Thrones is the type of show to leave
us hanging just like they did with Jon
and bran in earlier seasons bran has
seen Jon on two different occasions but
it was too dangerous for bran to
approach him and let him know he was
there if something happens to Jon Arya
or brand before they can all meet again
I would lose my effing mind this is the
last season so this is our last chance
to get these reunions I'm still trying
to get over the fact that Jon and Ned
will never see each other again and Robb
will never get to see Jon dressed all in
black but I'm hanging on to this last
glimmer of hope before the show comes to
an end
I would love to see all the remaining
members of House Stark together again in
Winterfell with the stark banner proudly
flapping in the wind I still have a
bunch of questions you left me and I'll
be answering those in the next one I
felt like I should use that one question
to turn into a separate video because it
all kind of flowed together let me know
what would be a sad ending for you do
you agree with any of the scenarios I
gave or do you have some different ones
these were just the first three that
popped in my head but I'm sure some of
you can bring some other ones to my
attention I would love to see what you
think also don't forget about the new
giveaway if you would like to enter for
a chance to win
the world of Ice and Fire book there is
a link down below I'll leave it in the
comments section you can enter up to
five different times to increase your
chances of winning good luck before I go
I just want to thank all of you for
taking the time to watch the video I
appreciate that as always and I can't
forget everyone on patreon who continues
to support the channel thank you all
very much have a great day I'll see you
soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you